it's true the press thinks Donald Trump
is stark raving mad the media Research
Center counted the words reporters used
to describe Trump and found he was angry
23 times furious 17 times outraged eight
times
he was also venting infuriated livid
erupting lashing out on a tirade the
good news no spontaneous combustion
that's for after the midterms so while
this language swells to make you think
the guy with the finger on that famous
button is bonkers absent any harmful
deeds by Trump and faced with booming
optimism about America's direction the
media is like a pack of cats looking for
a sack out to create a story that fits
their own infuriated furious eye bulging
narrative so the traffic in workplace
rumors the stuff that exists in all
offices since the beginning of cubicles
heck even Jesus dressed down his
apostles but we get at Trump's know
Jimmy Carter thank God
I mean who'd you rather have a nice guy
mocked by the world or a loudmouth who
keeps the world guessing and therefore
cooperating now Trump's bombastic but
most bosses are they use their voice
like an instrument as a call to action
to wake up the slackers to get the team
to do actual work that voice isn't there
to soothe the concerned or troubled
souls in the media and it's always about
the media they're like ignored teens and
they just hate the new guy who's making
them work for their strengths and drinks
they need someone who makes them feel
important by echoing their phony virtues
after Obama the media got so flabby they
should thank Trump he's the one who put
them on the pressroom diet where they
eat nothing but their own words anyway
let's just go to break I'm joking Dana
you made this point earlier that when
they when they talk about when President
Obama would get mad they described or
described as fiery if it's always a
common thing fiery as a compliment the
thing is with President Trump he's not
boring yes and you know and we have to
figure out a way to make something
interesting exciting unfair why would
somebody click on that why would
somebody buy that
so with President Trump they either use
all the ones that they use for President
Obama
if he was fiery that was like a good
thing because he was finally gonna get
out there and he's gonna show those
Republicans if he was frustrated that
was because Republicans were
obstructionist yeah okay and if he was
test the worst they ever said about him
is that he was testy or he was irritated
ya know and those things like that was
like the worst they ever said about well
actually the birth certificate thing was
pretty bad Jesse this is my favorite I
know it was just a joke alright they
said the president lashing out he was
lashing out fifty three times over six
months last he got that's almost I can't
do math but a lot yeah that's a lot I
mean listen if the media was calling me
a racist mentally ill collude er and
they were rating the rating my lawyers
offices I'd be lashing out a lot too but
I don't really believe it because I
don't think these networks have the type
of sources that would actually tell you
what the president's mindset is in that
inner sanctum in the Oval Office
I remember when who I don't but I look
back at when Bill Clinton was under
investigation by Special Counsel the
press called him resilient energized
invigorated strategizing passionate I
mean it's like it really tells you more
the adjectives that they use about the
media than about the person they're
describing for instance the media calls
me smarmy sarcastic all kinds of awful
things but if you look when when
nonpartisan real fair and balanced media
describe me they say I'm handsome
disciple funny it really just depends on
where it's coming back but your mom
actually said those other things Jude
what Jesse saying one if they followed
me around they could say that I yell
constantly and that I'm grumpy all the
time that I sing nonsense songs and that
I mutter to myself these are all
accurate that's all accurate right yeah
they do a better job with you
I don't know why it's not fair to Jessie
but I will say that to me they're just
too many sources here so like even if
you read conservative media they say
this president can be volatile and can
be impulsive he's unpredictable oh so I
don't know to me when you have him
described as fire and fury or fear or
unhinged I think these are book titles
right geez there's a lot of people
saying this I don't know three people
and many of them are liars liars leakers
and liberals and flippers and flipper
dealt with those people they're a bunch
of crooks doctor sapphire is there
something psychologically wrong with the
press I always get that psychological
the problem I have with this verbage is
it encourages single-minded certainty
and it really closes off all sorts of
compromise and ask anyone I work with
I'm even keel all day long until I'm
faced with incompetency and at that
point you can say that I get upset I'm
not throwing tantrums but you know I'm
upset they press called president Trump
angry 185 times since January 1 well you
know what he deals with incompetency
every day everything that he campaigned
on there obstructionists in the way
health care the wall I could we don't
have all day
but he's frustrated and that's why he's
angry I mean he should be and I think
that he might like to be described
differently but if you weren't described
in these ways he wouldn't be actually
getting done what he says are you
getting done so fear helps yeah yeah you
know how I describe him yes stable
genius